1945 1950 léon blum hommes politiques
emblématiques de l'histoire socialiste a
passé les dernières années de sa vie
dans cette maison une maison devenue
avec le temps lieu de visite est en
travaux depuis la fin 2016 700000 euros
investis pour améliorer notamment
l'accueil du public et entretenir le
devoir de mémoire
je vois bien en quoi c'est d'abord un
atout pour nos élèves donc l'aspect
pédagogique la dimension scientifique
était rappelée avec ce comité
scientifique est essentiel et je crois
que ça peut être un atout dans ce
travail de mémoire que nous devons mener
durant sa visite la ministre s'est
également rendu sur la tombe de celui
qui fut en 1936 chef de gouvernement du
front populaire époque où hitler
commencent à imposer sa vision à
l'europe et où l'espagne débute sa
guerre civile
il y à cette référence qu'on peut faire
à tout moment dans la vie de léon blum à
des situations réellement actuelle ça
peut être la menace de tel ou tel ou tel
extrémisme ça peut être la vision d'une
d'une ouverture sur le plan social ça
peut être la relation avec les pays
étrangers comme les états unis la
réouverture de la maison léon blum est
prévue pour septembre prochain les
travaux devraient permettre d'accueillir
jusqu'à 5000 visiteurs par an